ow that hurts oh Lily hi sweetheart come
here come here
if you ever
put your hands on my daughter again I
will string you up by your feet run you
up to flagpole let the birds Peck out
your eyes
you understand
boy down
he pulled my daughter's hair please
apologize to Connor for using your hands
instead of your words
sorry little fella
I would like to see you in my office
right now please me too
leave me alone
Mr Tucker what happened out there was
unacceptable I agree is this
kindergarten or The Hunger Games I'm
speaking of your behavior we've never
had an incident like this and now we've
had one on the first day before Circle
time
fudge were you thinking now the boys
parents are coming in and trust me
they're mad as Hello Kitty oh you told
his parents on us
that is so not cool well I'm sure once
they hear what their boy did they will
be understanding
all right whoever made our son cry has
messed with the wrong moms I am so sorry
we have to meet like this but I'm sure
you can understand his parents the
instinct to protect your child yeah it's
what makes me want to punch you in the
neck right now wow I see where your son
gets all of his aggression okay let's
all take a timeout that's a good idea
this is getting a little heated yeah Pam
we don't want another incident like at
the lumber yard oh my God you guys go to
the lumber yard too
I didn't know they had a ladies night
not the bar Sally okay you know what
he's trying to be nice and he just
called him Sally yeah you're not being
very helpful Peppermint Patty let's just
stick to our actual names enough
I'm gonna give you a little homework
assignment I want you and your kids to
have a family play date maybe if the
four of you can get along you can set a
better example for your children I think
that's a wonderful idea Pam
fine cam fine we'll host obviously
obviously well I assume you have an
unfinished woodworking project at your
house you've got a lot of nerve and
you've got half a canoe in our living
room
I look forward to your frittata oh why
are you visiting us in 2008
okay we have an assortment of spring
rolls here all vegetarian of course oh
because I'm a lesbian I'm automatically
a vegetarian
I saw it on the L word I assume they
have Consultants I'm just saying it's an
offensive stereotype okay Pam you are a
vegetarian oh knock it off worked out
yeah so glad that we are doing this yeah
yeah me too yeah I mean we're the only
gay parents in the class yeah we should
be supporting one another I mean we have
so much in common exactly
so
tell us about yourself I'm an
Environmental Lawyer and I'm a homemaker
and what do you do I'm a Financial
Consultant I'm a contractor
you thought I was a PE teacher I figured
hey I have a question real quick how do
you guys get the car seat on the
motorcycle uh you know Connor is having
a birthday next week maybe Lily would
like to come oh she would love that oh
great are you guys having a clown oh God
no I hate clowns they're so creepy maybe
you just don't like them because they
wear makeup
you know what I'm out
Connor we're leaving you don't
understand cam used to be a clown used
to be once a clown always a clown no no
not now let's stop it Connor let's go
foreign
right now
okay
I'm not hearing anything sure they're
fine how are you sure
Lily Connor Lily
Lily Connor if you can hear me
back away from the door I'm gonna break
it down I'll help you
oh thank God they're alive I
am oh you love the idea of him not open
this door sweetie
come here sweetheart if you ask me
sometimes we get so hung up on our
differences we forget the one thing we
have in common when it comes to the
safety and well-being of our children
we're all a little bit nuts
you have dainty little hands just like
your daughter you have boots like my dad
[Music]